hi I'm Jon Hamm this is brother Nick
Offerman and we are here with BuzzFeed
to play a first times the first kiss
first kiss his first kiss between us a
couple years ago it was like post seven
yeah my first kiss was in the seventh
grade and it was in the middle of the
street with a girl named Leslie we sat
in the middle of the street because that
seemed like a thing to do
yeah was it called the sack it wasn't
like an active motorway like a dare or
anything
it sounds really romantic mmm I'm
betting a cornfield had something to do
with this I guess my first kiss was at
the home of and he would have throw
parties for the young teenagers this is
already sending inappropriate and there
was a closet off his living room where
people would pair off be like you want
to go hang outs in heaven there was a
cute girl named Amy Baker had a very big
crush on her and I was pretty nerdy I
wasn't smooth what a jury ladies eighth
grade okay
I got her to go in the closet with me
and we kissed and she was like thank you
very much and and it's still you know it
took me a while then to find my mojo
because I definitely no one's got mojo
and there's energy when amy baker's
heart you're right if you do at 13 you
have peaked wildly early first person
you bonded with on set I'm gonna
discount the people I was already
friends with yes when we arrived I'm
gonna go with Jim o'heir oh nice I was
gonna say Pratt Pratt I already knew oh
you did yeah okay I met Pratt at a pool
party at Justin Long's house years
before everything about that sentence is
amazing and he immediately was
intelligent and hilarious and friendly
and I said I if you don't screw up your
I think you're gonna be a movie [ __ ]
turns out he did okay so you're welcome
you should get 10% of that I shipped
mine was probably Slattery for the
similar reasons that we had not really
met and the first day kind of all my
scenes were with John it was a very
challenging day of a lot of lines and a
lot of stuff and by the end of that
first days like I think I'm gonna be
friends with this guy first person you
call when you're having a bad day my
wife and best friend Megan Mullally and
answer is Ernest same person she's
actually really sweet to talk to and I
have her phone number
she is really empathetic she just
listens yeah sometimes you don't need a
talker
you need a listener first Wilde fan
experience the first wild fantasy Rian's
I had was I was wearing a robe in a
hotel room the sash of it got caught in
the ceiling fan and I got whipped around
that that room like once around real
quick
until the robe gave away and I ended up
sort of on all fours buns to the sky I
was wild that is one of many years ago I
was on the F train at the end of the
train I saw Paul Giamatti I told myself
don't do it don't do it and I weren't
famous at this end no it was just during
Parks and Recreation oh so it's an old I
know once I watch oh I went down to Paul
Giamatti and told him how good he was
and this movie called the hawk is dying
I had just seen at Sundance I
immediately was informed by his face
that I had made a grave mistake meaning
that it wasn't Paul Giamatti or that he
was not good now it may be it turns out
it was Kevin Bacon and he just was like
every you got everything you're saying
is wrong yeah
the first celebrity crush I'm gonna try
and tell the truth here Micky Dolenz of
the monkey Wow he got in there before
girls mattered mine has to be like man
Farrah Fawcett sure for sure up top
did you have the poster I was not
allowed
I don't think I was either but I found
it push up to the crush and I ruined it
first big purchase after getting your
first major role well here's the thing
people think that once you get a part in
anything that you're set that's not how
it works
at least I know it works for guys like
us honestly my first major purchase was
paying off my student loans and the debt
that I had accrued over the six years
after I got out of college before I
really worked at anything other than
being a waiter and a bartender that
stuff felt good to be able to be sort of
debt-free for the first time in your
life it actually feels better it doesn't
it's not as good of a story but it feels
better than what what people would think
they would like to hear which is like
yeah yeah ice cream Lambo with the
suicide doors I learned early on in my
career that each good job I got if I
bought a machine for my woodworking shop
instead of a bag of diamond cocaine
diamonds in cocaine would you know
cocaine is is crush time we call cocaine
diamonds in our house first time you
realized you wanted to be a part of the
Good Omens cast we both have talked
about there were longtime fans of the
writing of Neil Gaiman any time you hear
that one of your favorite writers one of
their works that's one of your favorite
books is going to be made into a thing
that you might get to play somebody in
two things happen for me
one is incredible excitement and the
other is dread when I heard they're
making Lord of the Rings
I wrote dogged letters for a couple of
years to Peter Jackson asking him to
audition me to play Samwise Gamgee after
about 18 months I was awarded an
audition for the role of Gimli that
immortal and they got some you know jerk
British guy
class first-timer of classic move so
there's that dread of their making some
a thing out of something that I love so
much you know it's hard to get into oh I
have my thing my version of that is the
Star Wars stuff and I think they've made
more Star Wars things with more people
in them
where's my phone call I've been a nerf
herder I gotta get the lingo so at least
we get to be in this yeah and I'm glad
you had this chance to call them out for
sure still a little upset
let's tell you breadth first experience
on a TV or movie set
this isn't gonna be an interesting one
for me and again this is a true story I
got to go visit the set of Jake and The
Fatman I was a little kid and I was
visiting my aunt out in California in LA
to be specific my uncle he knew a guy
that produced a TV show so he said you
want to go see a TV set he said how do
you feel about Jake and The Fatman and I
was like it's my favorite television
show in the world
it wasn't being nice sure got up really
early in the morning and we got to go
see Jake and/or the fat man do a scene
it was kind of like oh this is really
boring it wasn't really much happening
that's the lesson of visiting a site yes
there's a lot of downtime I don't think
I was on a set of any sort before my
first job which was in Chicago in 1993
or four I was just there for the summer
and I got cast as the bad guy on a show
called angel Street for CBS it was a
buddy cop show they spend the episode
finding me and it cuffed me and lead me
away and I in the episode and with me
saying what about my tools it was
actually I could see you really carrying
about I absolutely you can't believe
your tools out in an alley they're gonna
get rusty thank you very much
BuzzFeed this has been the first times
consider yourself blessed please tune in
to Good Omens
may 31st on Amazon Prime we're both in
it
to win it
[Music]